un espace fermé et protégé aux lumières
tamisées une musique d'ambiance une
guirlande bleu des petites lampes
blanches et vertes au plafond jean-paul
pitois souffrent de handicap sur ce
matelas haut il se relaxent la technique
porte un nom snozelen et les séances
durent entre 30 et 40 minutes
c'est un pari super on a plus
l'impression d'être à l'hôpital avec
monsieur pitoa c'est plus de la
relaxation avec un travail au niveau du
matelas à eau qui est celui de détente
et des mobilisations des massages avec
les balles après il ya d'autres
résidents où on est plus sur le
sensoriel donc à travailler avec les
fibres optiques le plafond lumineux
il ya des résidents qui sont très fermés
sur eux-mêmes et ça c'est vraiment un
espace où il s'ouvre aux autres et à la
relation
la méthode snoezelen de la contraction
de deux mots hollandais qui signifie
explorer et somnoler existe depuis 1970
aux pays bas en france ces salles ont
fait leur apparition dans les années 90
réserver aussi bien aux malades
d'alzheimer qu'aux personnes atteintes
de troubles moteurs ou cérébraux même
s'ils peuvent pas le dire parce qu'il ya
quand même des personnes qui viennent
ici qui ne peuvent pas exprimer avec des
mots mais on voit vraiment physiquement
la détente s'est très nettement pour
ceux qui ne peuvent pas quitter leur
chambre il existe un dispositif mobile
tout cela a un coût 13 1500 euros
financés intégralement pour cet hôpital
par le rotary club la santé est une
mission les enfants handicapés c'est une
mission
le
disons que le leitmotiv du rotary servir
d'abord la salle est installé depuis le
mois de juin une vingtaine de patients
bénéficient et de l'avis des
professionnels qui encadrent le
dispositif
tous les résidents se sont montrés très
réceptifs